20 prozent was für ein schlimmer
wahlsonntag für die spd vor allem im
ruhrgebiet haben sie bestimmt gelesen
hat die partei gute all verloren
wir schalten live in die gaststätte zum
scharfen steiger dort dort tagt in
diesen minuten der allerletzte spd
ortsverband von gelsenkirchen buer
unter der leitung des genossen matthias
matschke matschige wie ist denn die
stimmung
das kann ich ihnen sagen wie die
stimmung ist jetzt geht's los geht's los
[Applaus]
das hatten wir uns als kleine aktion
überlegt wegen aufbruchstimmung und zur
ecke
ja ich sag mal so an uns hier in
gelsenkirchen buer hat es am sonntag
nicht gelegen wir sind alle hingegangen
die roswitha der günther sogar der
jupiter und der ist tot
also wirklich jetzt zwei wochen vor der
wahl gestorben
leider wieder ausgestorben gestorben und
wir haben ihn trotzdem hin getragen in
die wahlkabine
das ist nämlich die spd klar
20 prozent ist suboptimal das sind 16
prozent weniger als wir 1994 geholt
haben mit rudolf scharping
herr matschie
ich will die noch in der wunde bohren
aber ich muss sagen bei ihnen in der
ehemaligen hochburg gelsenkirchen holt
die afd tatsächlich 17
was genau läuft denn das schief ich
bitte sie unser größter feind ist doch
nicht die afd
unser größter feind ist die biologie
seit der letzten wahl 2013 sind
insgesamt 760.000 spd-wähler verstorben
und snippet die zielgruppe ab was das
für ein gefühl ist musste ich ihnen als
zdf-mitarbeiter ja wohl nicht erklären
in der tat das ist
[Applaus]
co
problem nummer zwei die ganzen
minijobber und leiharbeiter sind immer
noch stinksauer auf die spd nur weil die
spd damals minijobs und leiharbeit
erfunden hat sowas von nachtragen die
leute aber wir schaffen jetzt trotzdem
die wände oder leute oder wir schaffen
die wende
was da kommt
wir starten wieder richtig durch und
zwar mit andrea nahles das ist ne
oppositionsführerin die wird der merkel
einheizen mit einer geilen
bundestagsrede nach der anderen
da da die ich mach mir die welt
widdewidde wie sie mir gefällt
[Applaus]
ach du scheiße güter deutlich zu sagen
bekommt nicht nur einen haben hier
wieder ruft den notarzt rief den notarzt
matthias matschke meine damen und herren
fielen
[Applaus]